c'est vous Rafael pitty bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes médecin
humanitaire à charger des missions
chargée de mission de formation à la
médecine de guerre auprès de mea d'une
ONG française de santé et de solidarité
internationale on vient de faire un
point terrain avec notre envoyé spécial
gulliverkra qui évolue à Liman la
situation humanitaire de l'Ukraine quel
était le aujourd'hui exactement on est
sept mois après le début de l'offensive
russe
alors il faut bien voir qu'il y a un
aspect un peu paradoxal à la fois toute
la violence toute la guerre se concentre
dans le nord-est du pays ça c'est
évident le reste du pays vit à peu près
normalement lorsque l'on va à le vivre
lorsque l'on va à Kiev la vie a repris
tous ses droits et les gens vont au
travail les enfants vont à l'école les
étudiants ont repris leur cours à
l'université donc globalement on est
dans un retour pratiquement à la
normalité dans les dans les zones en
dehors bien évidemment du nord-est du
pays et ça peut être effectivement
quelque chose un peu de paradoxal quand
on y va notre côté quand on y reste on
voit bien que la guerre est présente
certainement très fortement dans les
esprits chacun des Ukrainiens a
forcément quelqu'un qui est sur la zone
de combat et que ce soit un cousin un
ami un frère quelqu'un de la famille en
tous les cas et quand on est à vie ou à
Kiev il existe tous les jours des
cérémonies fun qui sont organisés car
les corps des soldats blessés retournent
dans leur ville et c'est là qu'il
reçoive effectivement le rituel
funéraire et c'est assez marquant c'est
entre une deux voire trois personnes à
la fois qui sont
qui sont avec les familles qui sont là
et pleurer qui crient etc et puis par
ailleurs il y a aussi l'incidence
économique l'Ukraine bien évidemment vit
une crise économique assez profonde et
on voit beaucoup de personnes âgées dont
les revenus ne sont pas très importants
contenus de l'inflation qui m'ont dit ou
qui sont dans des qui vendent qui
vendent des fleurs qui vendent des
petits objets pour essayer d'arrondir
leurs fins de mois
pour le pour le reste on peut avoir le
sentiment que on ne comprend pas
pourquoi au fond les réfugiés qui sont à
l'extérieur qui ont quitté keV à
l'époque de du mois de mars ne rentrent
plus dans leur pays mais il y a quand
même il faut bien le dire il y a environ
8 millions de personnes qui sont
déplacées à l'intérieur toutes celles tu
es dans le nord-est du pays
ce sont des placés et sont réfugiés à
l'intérieur même de leur pays qui n'est
pas sans poser un problème humanitaire
d'organisation justement pour la prise
en charge de ces 8 millions de personnes
et donc on est aujourd'hui dans cette
situation l'Ukraine a besoin d'aide sur
le plan humanitaire pour à la fois sa
population et celle qui est la plus
précaire et pour celle bien évidemment
qui est déplacé à l'intérieur de
l'Ukraine quand pour ces populations
pardonnez-moi quels sont les besoins
aujourd'hui j'imagine que certaines
zones du pays sont frappées par des
pénuries aussi des infrastructures qu'il
faut reconstruire la prise en charge
hospitalière notamment qui a un vrai
problème
alors là sur le plan l'organisation de
la prise en charge des zones de combat
vers l'arrière sont très très bien
organisés par les militaires eux-mêmes
il y a peu de victimes civiles il y en a
bien évidemment mais ils sont peu
nombreux et ce sont surtout des
militaires qui sont qui font les frais
bien évidemment de tous ces combats et
il y a une organisation sanitaire qui
est parfaitement bien organisée avec le
ramassage sur place les hôpitaux qui
sont juste civils des militaires qui
sont juste sur l'arrière que ce soit les
hôpitaux de carquive de mikolaï font de
stabilisation de plus de structures de
stabilisation puis ensuite les victimes
les blessés sont évacués vers l'arrière
et surtout vers les hôpitaux militaires
peu dans les hôpitaux civils vous vous
êtes rendu en Ukraine pour finaliser
justement l'installation d'un centre de
formation à la à la médecine de guerre
c'est vrai que ça ne s'improvise pas ça
ne s'invente pas concrètement qu'est-ce
que vous avez fait là-bas et qu'elles
étaient les besoin les attentes
écoutez on se retrouve autant au mois de
mars où nous craignons effectivement une
invasion de l'Ukraine avec un impact
très important sur les structures
civiles qui allaient être forcément mis
en avant dans la prise en charge des
victimes surtout de la population et
c'est ce qui avait motivé la mise en
place de notre centre de formation à
vivre pour former le personnel civil à
la prise en charge des blessés de guerre
bien évidemment aujourd'hui comme je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure les
hôpitaux civils en dehors des zones de
combat sont peu impactés par la
situation de guerre alors nous nous
efforçons au contraire d'améliorer la
prise en charge des médecins qui sont
sur les zones de combat et là en
particulier ce qui nous a semblé très
important c'est de les former à
l'utilisation d'un micro appareil qui
est un échographe qui permet justement
de faire des diagnostics assez précis et
de trier correctement les les
victimes et donc nous employons
justement actuellement à former
essentiellement à l'utilisation de ces
de ces échographes et nous les donnons
même nous les donnons à toutes les
structures qui en ont besoin
voilà une aide aussi sur sur ce plan sur
ce plan là un solidarité exprimé aux
Ukrainiens à votre tour de votre voyage
en Ukraine vous avez parlé d'un voyage
particulièrement éprouvant vous avez dit
la vie ne compte pas pour Vladimir
Poutine quel a été la réalité à laquelle
vous avez été confronté pendant ce
déplacement écoutez pas véritablement de
ce que j'ai dit relevé de toute
l'expérience que nous avions tiré durant
ces dix années en Syrie et lorsque nous
avons dit la vie pour Poutine ne compte
pas pour les Russes ne comptent pas il
massacre ils ont un objectif et ils
fonce sans se préoccuper des populations
qui sont pris au piège bien évidemment
des bombardements de la terreur de la
fin bien sûr puisqu'ils assiègent ils
coupe l'eau l'électricité etc
les victimes ne comptent pas seul
l'objectif compte et vous et vous voyez
c'est exactement ce que l'on voit ce
qu'on a vu à Mario Paul et ce qu'on
continue à voir ou même à découvrir avec
ses charniers que l'on découvre dans les
zones qui ont été occupées par les
Russes il y a l'homme ne compte pas seul
l'objectif compte et c'est terrible de
voir de devoir se combattre avec des
gens qui ne respectent rien
les Ukrainiens que vous avez rencontré
alors pour beaucoup des médecins
évidemment dans quel état d'esprit
sont-ils aujourd'hui on voyait dans le
reportage il y a quelques instants que
toutes ces villes qui viennent d'être
libérées par l'armée ukrainienne
évidemment ce serait jouissent mais
reste très prudente des jours des
semaines qui vont arriver
alors c'est clair qu'on peut s'attendre
à une contre-offensive russe avec cette
mobilisation justement de ces 300 000
hommes certainement qu'il va y avoir une
contre-offensive et qu'il faut
s'attendre dans les semaines à venir
justement à une recrudescence des
combats et j'espère très très fortement
que les Ukrainiens seront faire face à
cette contre-offensive parce que les
Russes n’hésiteront pas à utiliser même
le chimique c'est cela est nécessaire
vous qui avez travaillé en Syrie pour la
Syrie et des aider les Syriens est-ce
que vous y voyez une comparaison on
redoute aujourd'hui un conflit qui ne
qui ne s'éternise
oui et je pense que les Russes sont
assez bien que nous l'avons vu en Russie
le temps ne compte pas ils prennent le
temps qui est nécessaire et ils n'ont
pas d'autres objectifs que de réussir
[Musique]
d'aboutir à leurs fins et donc qu'il
prendront le temps nécessaire d'être et
il n'hésiteront pas à terroriser les
populations il n'hésiteront pas utiliser
le chimique je le dis
bombarder d'une manière très intensive à
assiéger ils le feront de nouveau comme
ils l'ont toujours fait comme ils l'ont
fait en Syrie et on peut s'attendre dans
les semaines à venir à cette
contre-offensive et qui sera terrible
les sucres en plus on rentrera dans la
période hivernale et ça va être une
période extrêmement difficile
l'hiver pour les Ukrainiens alors c'est
ça bien évidemment les les
Ukrainiens se sont battus maintenant
depuis plus de six mois ils sont sur la
zone
pourront-ils résister il faut l'espérer
avec l'hiver les choses vont
certainement prendre une autre tournure
et il faudra bien évidemment bien
évidemment l'Ukraine n'a pas fait sa
mobilisation générale donc elle a un
potentiel de réserve d'hommes qui
peuvent aller bien évidemment se battre
et j'espère en tous les cas que nous
saurons nous les occidentaux les aider
merci beaucoup Raphaël pitty d'avoir été
avec nous médecins humanitaire auteur
également d'un livre va où l'humanitaire
te porte un médecin dans la guerre merci
d'avoir été notre invité du jour